POLITICIANS.
THE STATE IS IN CHARGE.
THE PARTY IS IN CHARGE.
OBVIOUSLY AND IT'S HAPPENING ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, A LONG TIME,
MORE THAN A YEAR.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FIGHT FOR
OUR SCHOOLS IN VIRGINIA AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN US
TONIGHT, IAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
YOU WONDER IF PARENTS IN YOUR
STATE ARE AWARE OF JUST HOW --
THIS HASN'T GONE AWAY, JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
WE HAVE A SEEN ALL THESE VIDEOS
OF ANGRY PARENTS AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS BUT THEY'VE GOT EVEN
MORE AGGRESSIVE IN PUSHING IT OR
AM I IMAGINING THAT.
>> NO, THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND THIS BILL BEING PUSHED IN
VIRGINIA BY ELIZABETH GUZMAN IS
EVIL BUT PREDICTABLE.
I MEAN THIS IS WHERE IT GOES.
WE'VE BEEN DEALING IN VIRGINIA,
ESPECIALLY NORTHERN VIRGINIA,
WITH SCHOOLS THAT SAY, WELL,
LOOK, IF JUDY COMES TO THE
SCHOOL COUNSELOR AND SAYS I WANT
TO BE JOHN NOW, WE DON'T HAVE TO
TELL THE PARENT UNLESS THE
STUDENT GIVES US PERMISSION.
AND THE REASON WHY THEY DON'T
TELL THE PARENT IS BECAUSE THE
PARENT MIGHT NOT AFFIRM THAT.
AND THE SCHOOLS CONSIDER THAT AN
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT.
ABUSIVE.
RIGHT?
SO THAT'S WHY THE PARENTS DON'T
GET TO KNOW.
THIS IS THE NATURAL PROGRESSION.
A LAW THAT SAYS, YES, WE AGREE
IT'S ABUSIVE AND SINCE IT'S
ABUSIVE NOW WE'RE GOING TO SEND
CPS AFTER YOU FROM YOU FOR
FELONIES AND MISDEMEANORS AND
DESTROY YOUR LIVES AND DESTROY
YOUR EMPLOYMENT AND WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE YOUR KIDS FROM YOU.
WHAT ELIZABETH GUZMAN DID WAS
ENTIRELY PREDICTABLE AND ALL THE
DEMOCRATS LIKE ABIGAIL SPAM
BURGER AND JENNIFER WESTON WHO
TRIES TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM THIS, YOU CAN'T.
YOU ALREADY SAID YOU SUPPORT
SCHOOLS KEEPING THIS INFORMATION
FROM PARENTS.
YOU ARE COMPLETELY OKAY WITH
THIS AGENDA AND YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO OUTRUN IT.
>> Tucker: BUT TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
ELIZABETH GUZMAN FROM PERU,
THEY'RE NOT YOUR KIDS' PARENTS,
YOU'RE YOUR KIDS' PARENTS.
WHERE DO THEY GET THE RIGHT TO
MAKE THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS
FOR YOUR CHILDREN?
>> THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT.
I MEAN, THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES PARENTS
THE RIGHTS TO THE CARE, CUSTODY
AND CONTROL OF THEIR CHILDREN.
SO IF THEY TRIED THIS THEY WOULD
BE ROUNDLY DEFEATED IN COURT.
ABOUT YOU THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS FOR PEOPLE LIKE ELIZABETH
GUZMAN AND HER ALLIES, IF YOU GO
AND YOU'RE READING YOUR KIDS'
BOOKS ABOUT TRANSGENDERISM AT
FIVE, GETTING THEM ON PUBERTY
BLOCKERS, GIVING THEM
TESTOSTERONE AND GETTING A
DOUBLE MASTECTOMY.
YOU'RE A GREAT PARENT.
OTHERWISE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THAT, THEY'RE GOING TO PROSECUTE
YOU, PUT YOU IN JAIL AND YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE YOUR KIDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE
THEM.
>> YEAH, WELL, LIVE AND LET
LIVE.